لقد كانت عاصفة لم يشهدها أي ليبي آخر
من قبل، ولكن ليس
غضب الطبيعة الأم وحده هو المسؤول
عن هذه المشاهد المروعة في درنة،
فهناك حيث كانت السدود
عندما انفجرت وأطلقت العنان لكل تلك
المياه والفيضانات التي اجتاحت
أحياء بأكملها.  مثل هذا في البحر
ويمكنك رؤية قوة الماء عندما
تنظر إلى المباني مثل هذا
ويمكنك أن ترى مدى ارتفاع
الأمواج التي يصل ارتفاعها إلى 22 قدمًا أو 7 أمتار
وهي تغمر المباني والتيارات
القوية جدًا دمرت كل شيء تقريبًا
مسارها وجرفها كلها إلى البحر،
وتحول البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​إلى
مقبرة لأهل درنة. كم
عدد الأرواح التي فقدت هنا لا أحد يعرف حقًا،
لكنها بالآلاف،
المياه الزرقاء الصافية الآن غامضة وبنية
اللون تحكي القصة القاتمة لـ  المدينة التي
كانت ذات يوم من بين أولئك الذين ذهبوا صغارًا وكبارًا
وأطفالًا يبلغون من العمر بضعة أشهر وكبار السن
والنساء الحوامل وهم في البحر، يبلغ من العمر 21
عامًا، يخبرنا عبد الوهاب أنه
لم يكن لديه سوى حبل مربوط حول خصره،
وقام بسحب 40 جثة في اليوم الأول
يقول إن هناك جثث أخرى لا
نعرف كيفية إخراجها، ليس
لدينا أي معدات، ويقول
إنك لن تراها مرة أخرى، لقد
حصلوا على بعض المساعدة لأن
الدعم الدولي كان
يتدفق ببطء ولكن ليس قريبًا بدرجة كافية
للتعامل مع كارثة بهذا الحجم،
معظمهم من الليبيين هنا، متطوعون من
كل ركن من أركان هذا البلد المنقسم بمرارة،
الأعداء الذين قاتلوا بعضهم البعض
لسنوات متحدين في الحزن يفعلون ما في
وسعهم لتضميد جراح هذه المدينة المكسورة،
معظمهم هنا لمحاولة تقديم المساعدة  الموتى
نهاية كريمة،
ليس هذا هو الوقت المناسب لإلقاء اللوم على ما
حدث، كما يقول الكثيرون، لكن السدود لم
تتم صيانتها منذ عقود،
ويقول السكان إنه لو كانت دينا،
فربما كان شعبها لا يزال يقف
على مشاعره لمدة أسبوع تقريبًا هنا ولا يزال
مقيدًا للغاية  وتسلقت عائلته
فوق خزانات المياه الموجودة على سطح منزلهم، وقد
نجوا جميعًا ولكن معظم
جيرانه لم يصمتوا.
هناك 12 إلى 15 منزلًا في شارعنا
فقدنا 33 شخصًا، أخبرنا
أنه ثم يتشخر ليذكر اسم
العائلة الميتة بأكملها.  لقد انتهى كل شيء،
ولم يكن هناك أي خسارة أو موت على الإطلاق،
ولكن لا شيء يمكن أن يعدهم لذلك